i got a really interesting voicemail
that i want to play for you of course
you can call the voicemail number any
time of day the number is 219 to david p
here is a voicemail about why do people
who are anti-semitic
claim to love israel it doesn't make
sense
hey david i was just wondering if you
had any insights into
why these people that hate jews so much
are so pro-israel
i don't get it
thank you there's a couple different
things going on number one
um
a lot of the evangelical support for
israel
is not rooted in any
uh uh desire
to um provide a safe haven for jews that
have been persecuted and you know dozens
and dozens of countries for a thousand
years or longer it's it's not rooted in
that for many evangelicals it's rooted
in
we believe the second coming of jesus
will happen
when there is a strong israel and then
there's a bunch a bunch of different
versions of it when a temple is rebuilt
or what whatever okay but basically they
believe that the second coming of jesus
will happen if they support israel
others believe the rapture will happen
if they support israel for some it's one
and the same there's all these different
sects and and they tend to have
different beliefs so that's part of it
um and then for many others on the right
um it's either
just they sort of like militarism and
they like the idea of there's uh other
countries that have some of the cool
advanced weapons that we have and or
uh they
see it as a way to sort of fight proxy
wars against populations they don't like
in the middle east but it's not it's i
understand that it sounds like wait a
lot of these people are anti-semitic
they often play into anti-semitic tropes
repeat them etc but they claim to
support israel they are two completely
different things and
much the same as
what is going on with american
anti-semitism
is a separate issue from israeli foreign
policy
the anti-semites who claim to like
israel are sort of operating in two
different spaces and it might sound like
it's one incoherent space and to some
degree it is but for many of them these
are completely different issues there's
the political state of israel and then
there's
jews about whom they have
uh uh prejudiced beliefs
in the united states and sort of the
day-to-day community it's a very good
question because it does seem incoherent
and inconsistent in in a sense it
absolutely is we have a great bonus show
for you today i'm out of time but trust
me it's a good one sign up at
joinpackman.com and you'll get instant
access